Can you please explain the BU and the bun test on my lab work?
So the bun on your lab work that's typically seen on a comprehensive metabolic profile. That stands for blood urea, nitrogen.
And it's a biomarker reflecting how you break down protein and
how it's how it's how your kidneys aren't getting rid of it.
So the simplest terminology, if you have an elevated BUN, that means you have stress on your kidneys.
So your kidneys are undergoing stress for some reason.
So it's not indicative of, you know, anything, you know,
again, just like any test, it gives you clues.
But elevated BUN is their stress out your kidneys.
Could it be because of kidney dysfunction?
So the kidneys could be dysfunctioning.
So you could have renal disease elevating your BUN.
You could have something more simple, like even dehydration would elevate your BUN.
Hypochloridria, beating decreased hydrochloric acid, and your stomach would elevate BUN.
Because you're going to have incomplete breakdown of proteins in your gut.
You could have, it's things like access, you know, somebody who's on a
carnivore type diet where they're eating tons of meat, you know, more than normal.
They will have an elevated BUN.
So you kind of got to break it down.
You're going to look at lifestyle of that person.
You wouldn't automatically jump to renal disease.
But again, so where would we see elevated BUN with somebody who has a previous cancer diagnosis?
You would have to look at how is this is this person on a medication?
Because medications can can damage your kidneys and then that can give you an elevated BUN.
So remember all lab tests are clues to something else.
So we've seen people on, you know, chemotherapy have an elevated BUN.
Because the chemotherapy has damaged their kidneys and until that gets cleared out
and their kidneys can heal, they may have an elevated BUN.
We've had people with taking venbendazole, or Ivermectin, have an elevated BUNs.
Similar to them having an elevated alkaline phosphatase, AST, or ALT.
Those are liver markers showing that that is causing stress to the liver.
So there's all sorts of things that can cause stress to organs.
So elevated BUN is going to say, hey, they're stressed to my kidneys.
What is causing it?
Is it because of not properly breaking down proteins?
Because I have a decreased hydrochloric acid production of my stomach.
Is it because I have dehydration?
So I'm having difficulty breaking down proteins and I have elevated urea.
Do I have kidney damage because of a drug that I'm taking, even a adrenal stress could cause of elevated BUN?
And edema could cause elevated BUN.
So if I have an excess edema due to, let's say, blockage of lymphatic flow could cause an elevated BUN.
So there's a lot of reasons why that you need to flush them up by looking at the person's history.
You need to flush out by looking at what else is going on with this person that could be leading to this.
All blood tests give us clues.